want to welcome all the new listeners
because we've been getting more and more
new listeners here and i want to give
you an idea of exactly how this works we
go live
every wednesday three o'clock central
four o'clock eastern
on youtube twitter and twitch
that's where we're at so you can find us
there you can go to thetonymichaels.com
to find
all those links uh to the youtube to the
twitter and to the twitch and then what
happens once we get done recording
because it's live
what i do is i take the audio and i
upload it to the interwebs to apple
podcast to spotify to google all the
directories so if you would rather
listen to the podcast as opposed to
watch my ugly face
then you can absolutely go download it
on spotify apple google all your
directories
it's uploaded
almost as soon as we're done here it
takes a little bit to get it uploaded
but once we're done
doing the live show then we upload it
for you to download if you want to
listen to it otherwise you can find us
on youtube
you can find us on twitter and you can
find us on twitch i don't know exactly
what twitch is but it's there
whatever it is it's there
and you can always find the videos on
youtube and follow us subscribe on
youtube follow us on twitter uh follow
on twitch if you're on twitch all that
kind of good stuff but go to
thetonymichaels.com find all those links
there
uh if you're a new listener to find out
what the what the whole shebang is about